oh he's got tats he's sleeved out he's
got the fit shirts on dude he'll see
your girl right now he will and he's got
a and he's got [ __ ] well my girl
likes mold
but he's i know but still you bring your
girl like let's say around him you're on
a train to europe and you're like oh
we're here for a few days yep
and then he takes one look at you one
look at him yeah game over yeah
you know you know you look like [ __ ] no
it's all good until she gets drunk
probably and then she's all like what am
i kissing this guy for you
you know what dude you're a better
looking pete wentz because pete looks
like [ __ ] up there
yeah he's a better looking pete wentz i
heard he's a good guy oh i know that kid
i met him
no you didn't yeah he used to date
ashley uh yeah actually
i met him uh because i know her i did
seventh heaven so i did her
i knew her for two years so yeah he's a
nice kid do you remember actually
simpson
had that beak forever and then she got
it fixed and
fully redeemed herself i yeah i uh i
don't i'm not going to comment on her
nose but i do remember there was a
change
oh yeah but why wouldn't you i was just
old and she was 16 she's that toucan sam
knows i'm not going to say that i'm not
going to say that
but no it's gone that's in the past
daddy can you not say to cancer
you know it like brennan will take
things too far are we rolling yep
yep because he'll take things far like
he'll be like hey yeah does this guy
know i could turn him into my own rake
reek
i was like what he goes i just cut his
dick off and put him in the [ __ ] cage
i was like
hey man this is game of thrones like if
you said i can slap him around it's fine
to give him a little shove around let
his dick offs too far and put him in a
cage and make him your
you know my roots my yeah
it seems to be a bit how is how's europe
daddy now you left me for two
you know what's fascinating about you
you know what's
fascinating finally you're back
finally the kid the fighting kid is
fully back he went
hell yeah dude this is great hey i'm
going to leave for
two weeks and and you figure it out
nobody
the only oh okay i got that okay it's
gonna sting a little bit so here's the
thing i know it's and it's great and
it's great being back
i'm gonna leave for two weeks and i need
you to figure out on your own yeah
oh no doubt yeah okay you did you didn't
bat an eye
no no but but the problem is that
there's only one person that might do
the only person that does better on
vacation
is you because i do terrible i can't go
on vacation for that long
four days what happens is four days
because what happens is i went look
i had a great time i ate some of the
best food in the world drink some of the
best wine please don't show me pictures
i won't never pictures yeah i'm another
one that's another thing i ain't a guy
who takes any pictures on holiday
i don't have any pictures of my european
trip
on my phone i just don't do it and i was
in a medieval unless there's a naked
cheek in it i don't see your picture
from the vacation that's right
you're not saying i wasn't if you're
like okay check out this hot naked girl
we ran
past i'd be like oh let me see the
picture there you go put this picture
your food
right stuff i can google or how about
you know what drives me nuts so my dad
tells me about
the plane he took yeah to europe yeah
now that's a plane
yeah that's a chateau and i made a joke
about how i was going to tear it down
because
i thought they uh hung people if you
wear v-necks in italy
hey hey hey now come on now
get out there no you're being you're
being shitty right now and you're acting
like you're not that's right
no hold on at least at least your hair's
combed in the back
i just woke up from a nap hey man do
some cocaine
um
[Laughter]
did you see that one no where is that i
play it again it's the take off from the
dog
what's up what do you want to do we
could still go outside for a walk we
could
watch a movie we could play pool eat
some lunch
do some cocaine um cocaine
who is that who's talking about hey mark
mark's so funny so you just went all
over huh my buddy who
has made some cash you know uh said come
and just come for free
and i'll take you by free means daddy's
paying for it all yeah pays for
everything yeah you're sidetracked
i'm i'm a side you're the oldest oldest
side chick in the world oh yeah you're a
sugar baby low sugar baby a little sugar
that's right a little sugar green i'm a
little i'm a sugar not a sugar rinky no
i'm beyonce
i used to be a twink now i'm a rinky
twink's out the window i'm a little
ranky
i'm a little rinky if you like them gray
and rinky and all kinds of passions i
did
you're a guy yeah and he's a big big fan
would you just stay with him and stuff
that's always weird right i stayed with
him but he's got when you when you when
you have that much
museum when you have that many houses
you never see them you don't have any
problems
and then i i tried surfing now here's
the thing about
when you go to south of france certain
parts of south france have real big
waves
and they kick up right quick and i don't
know if you know anything about
riptide but i don't current and the
riptide are something you got to take in
the consideration yeah
not very uh not very you know daddy gets
swept out by the tide well so daddy
decided to try surfing couldn't catch a
wave
i don't have a wave don't have wave
knowledge
and the waves started kicking and i went
i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here then i
went out with flippers
and uh boogie board now the area i was
in is so rough
that they have two blue flags that are
about as wide as
two of these rooms and you'll stay in
there if you're swimming because you go
outside that's where the
that's where you get caught up with the
current and so they have five lifeguards
not four but five
who have the they're all professionals
and they're on a tower this big
steel thing and they're just watching
everything like this yeah and people die
there all the time so you can't go
outside
if you want to go outside the flags got
to have a wetsuit
and flippers and a board of some kind
yeah
well i'm just following the guys who say
we're going to go boogie boarding
but old bride doesn't really know i'm
not a salty dog i don't really know how
to navigate
when the waves kick up like the
himalayas what happened hold on
the youngest was how old uh well i'm the
oldest there who's the youngest
the youngest uh the youngest out of the
group 30 30
right boogie boards are a no-no that's
right and it's a big difference
yeah and especially when you don't when
they keep going just go under the waves
and i don't have to go like this i'm
just making it i'm just now i'm out in
the
goose and i just ride this and i ride up
and i come down like
and now i'm kind of in the middle of
nowhere and they go catch this wave
and i i i catch the wave but i look as
i'm going as
i've been swept all the way out and
they're
high tide they're rocks so what happens
to hobrice i get taken
and oh sandbar has day to day yeah that
was a great
break your neck dad i did i i hurt my
back you broke my head having trouble
with my neck right here
from the boogie board and then i
couldn't get back gonna be a guarantee
couldn't get back get back how did you
tweak your neck
boogie board yeah yeah oh okay what's
better is i couldn't get back to shore
because i kept getting
taken men had to save you so so
my friend the surfer came and goes
that's very embarrassing hold on to my
board he said grab my
grab my leash oh no and then he's
paddling
and you're hanging on the leash like
this well dude i had one hand the other
hand was like this and i was like
i got it dude let's go and i was kicking
reality was like this
i helped him and then i got into water
that wasn't as choppy
yeah the sea when she wants to take it
now
is there is there some little uh
frenchie sharks out there in those
waters or no
no sharks in the french you're not
thinking about the sharks well you're
just trying to when
but are there sharks when the current
waves are great whites fancy not french
i don't think there's been any attacks
in france look at this well
what ocean is that out there
mediterranean sea
no this is the atlantic oh those those
are stupid don't have to worry about
those
yeah this is this is a mediterranean no
sharks none of them talk about that
now in in australia where my friend is
from
he was surfing there and he's not
surfing there anymore and i said why and
he said
well here's the thing about australia
right now
you hear about people disappearing and
they drown but they don't find them
shark what's happening what's happening
is that they are
they're protecting the sharks they're
over
fishing their food and getting rid of
the seals
yeah so now you so there are people in
australia that say i'm going to swim
i'm going to do my long distance
swimming yeah
and now they're just out there every day
swimming in
you know you know when you see those
people that are way offshore they're
just doing their laps
well those people now are starting to
get picked go missing yeah
that's australia that's what you get
yeah i wouldn't
so there's there's nothing in the french
it says like rare
very wow yeah that'd be the place we saw
a dolphin when we were
when we were surfing when i was trying
to start but you get a little scared
because they kind of look like sharks
yeah when you see the gray fin you're
like oh [ __ ] yeah it's a dolphin
yeah i don't like that i don't like it
either so the whole thing was uh
it was interesting you got some rest
though i guess
yeah you know when i'm resting when i'm
working when i'm being productive i
can't stand
i feel like just gotta just gotta relax
and do nothing i mean that'll really
stress me out yeah
but i will say that i'm to say this i
think money buys happiness
did your friend seem happy when you have
that much money when you have it
that's normal to him though yeah but no
i'm being silly but when
like you know there's money and then
there's there's this money where you go
um
look that way you see all the way can
you see as far as you can
see as far as you can see there that's
my property you understand it's like
game of thrones yeah yeah
that's that's when you when you you
survey your land
on your horse which is what he does but
he still has problems everybody wakes up
pretty soon
everybody does man the summer is here
and you're in the gym you're getting in
shape you're ditching that quarantine 30
you put on like your boy here and you're
doing everything right
but you like to sip on some cold ones
but you don't want all the calories
that's your carbs the sugar
what are you gonna do you want to reach
for a cold one well then core said hold
on
literally hold my bear because we got
coors pure
that's right coarse pure you're working
out hard
you're trying to eat healthy you're
trying to keep up with the wellness
trends of the day you're doing all that
well now get it with your beer
new new course pure is refreshingly
simple beer
with organic barley organic hops water
92 calories and
zero sugar zero freaking sugar man
zero so you can drink some of those bad
boys and they're delicious
and you're not gonna crush your diet
with that stuff man and it's gonna give
you the fix that you're looking for
coarse pure is the perfect bear
to celebrate the winds of life every day
so when you wanna enjoy a beer
without the guilt reach for coors pure
it's organic but they're chill about it
they're all up in your face like
organic no they're not that man go to
coorspure.com
see where you can find coors pure
celebrate responsibly coors
brewing company albany georgia hey man
as a business owner and there's a lot of
us
out there your entrepreneur yep and you
know exactly what you do with a little
extra cash all right you know what you
want to do
maybe you want to launch a new website
maybe you want to spend more time
marking your services or finding new
more creative ways to build your brand
whatever you're looking for man what you
really need is fiverr that's f-i-v-e-r-r
your one-stop shop for world-class
freelance talent that's right
the one-stop shop man whatever you're
looking for fiverr connects businesses
like yours
with freelancers to get the job done yep
offering hundreds of digital services
whatever you're looking for
so you can stop feeling overwhelmed and
start growing your
business fiverr's global network of
on-demand freelance
artists are super talented and their
hair to help man
whatever you're looking for find your
talent begin working on your project
within minutes
it's easy all right super easy customize
your search by
service deadline price seller reviews
and so much more
no more guessing games you know exactly
what you're paying for up front
no geek no no negotiating is needed
price is always
project based not hourly right 24 7
customer service
reach out whenever you want any time all
right we got you covered man check out
fiverr.com that's
f-i-v-e-r-r dot com and receive 10 off
your first order
by using the code fighter find all the
digital services you need in one place
at f i v e r r.com code fighter again
that's fiverr.com code fighter
everybody does yes you are correct even
with all that land there's
there's problems it doesn't matter
you're still gonna like jeff bezos has
promised he wakes up every day with that
[ __ ] eye
he's going he's going to space because
he's bored well think about that yeah
they're so bored they're all going to
space i'm going to space and then how
about the the guy from virgin
you didn't get the space dude you went
really high in a play you know he did he
did
he didn't get your breath out of space
you know like nasa's like
that's not out of space dude he didn't
break no he didn't breathe the
atmosphere
no he was still he didn't get to the
black he still
and also he went really high and i mean
i are you that bored
i was gonna say like i got a lot to do
down here
if if you said bro you're getting a
rocket and you're going to break
the atmosphere i'm not going you know
what i mean but also
you got a lot of risks also i think
they're lying they're like yeah we have
200 people waiting to sign up and get
them i'm not buying that either man
and it's also super expensive to get
there well my girl
we see we're we're out in my friend's
farm and we see a glider we see a glider
oh the people that are just like no not
that's hang gliding
then there are there are planes where
you you're it's a glider oh yeah no
no engine and they're just like that's
right now i don't know if you know how
they do this but
my girl says i've always wanted to get
in a glider
to which i always go i don't give a [ __ ]
about gliders
i don't care about hot water i don't
care about hot air balloons gliders
all that [ __ ] has passed for me all of
it just i'm a party pooper but your girl
wants to go in the garage she's dying to
go on a glider
we go we go which is five minutes down
the road
in this big open field and uh they you
know how they get you up in a glider
yeah they have to uh by another plane
pulling you right that would be like one
way that would be one way super safe
yeah because people get [ __ ] up just
going on a regular plane though you know
in this case they just had on remote
control a cable
that will pull you and you'll do you'll
get to 60 miles an hour in two seconds
it just goes and it's just cable along
the ground that
kicks you up and you got to know how to
i guess
ride it but sometimes a cable breaks and
it's
a bad day for you and then they just get
what you're doing
they get way up in the air and they just
they just
you know so did she do it or no no but
she wanted to
is is there a professional steering that
[ __ ] thing well there's a there
there's a club there and now here's the
thing about that
i got caught up in the glider club
because they came over and started
talking to us about
how there are great places dude you know
what now
the glider club i bet the diversity is
ridiculous
i bet dude it's just a melting pot it's
such a mess of diverse
so many it's like the united nations so
many black people who collect
well they have guys attached to their
car yeah yeah no there's a lot of color
yeah
there's not they're not old english
people yes in terrible clothing at all
yeah no um and by the way when you're
when you're in a glider it's i believe
it's english law you must wear a
parachute well the advantage of gliding
is you don't there's no engine
so you can hear everything yeah there's
no advantage
i'd say there's no way let's go let's go
on a plane without a motor yeah
and then you just glide around and it's
super quiet i guess it's peaceful
did you and your girl get in a fight
about it because she want to do that
stupid [ __ ]
no i just i i was going to say you can
go
yeah i go you go i'll watch from here
yeah oh you know what i'll do honey i'll
uh record on my phone i could give a
[ __ ] about gliding and they have them
you train a paper plane in trailers
yeah or they or they have them dragging
behind
you know and while we're at it there are
certain hobbies like horseback riding
that's another one you better have all
the money and and the
upkeep and you ride the horse sometimes
in a ring
and it's very i just i i'm not into it
man
horseback riding for me is like
ziplining you go once you're like
i'm good man and there's like how long
around this for the next four hours
i'm on this horse for four years i did
that in costa rica i was the worst
jay we went to costa rica yeah yeah you
go once you're like oh wow this is
pretty cool up here and then they're
like how many more like
oh you gotta travel the whole jungle and
back like oh [ __ ]
see ya god oh look there's a trail like
[ __ ]
trees whoa that's it get the [ __ ] out of
here
zip fighting that's it dude yeah dude
this is the last day in the studio man
we're gonna burn it down after the show
we're gonna burn this place down
turn into chin wants to burn it down he
said do you chin i gotta be honest with
you
i don't know if you're training for our
fight but you're looking good thank you
you've been losing weight chin are you
sick you look
better your forearms are vascular i'm
very happy with your forearm chin's
thinner now do you shave your forearms
you naturally that [ __ ] smooth
amazing dude
congratulations you ever seen a hairy
asian dude i mean he doesn't everything
he's talking all thin and handsome
except for indians
you know what kind of asian i'm talking
about yeah
yeah chin's losing weight i don't know
if i am great
i want to gain weight though muscle well
you just gotta lift i know which i
haven't done yet
well we got a couple thick boys i've
never seen two of you guys this booby
you got tits for days booby all i can
see is tits and
i wish we could take some of jay's tits
and put it in yours well dude i
uh as an athlete i got my back is what
my shirt drives me nuts
let me ask you something where's bobcat
wrestling go huh where where is it
what where's the league where where's
that [ __ ] from yes
i do wrestling yeah i know you do yeah
but where's that shirt from bobcat
wrestling yep
high school florida florida yeah
wrestling i was doing stand-up
some guys charlotte and a guy gave me
an honorary shirt from he was a coach
bobcat wrestling
and i like to wear it why because i like
that people go home people
that guy looks like he's probably a
wrestler it's my favorite thing to do
and i'm 54.
wow still haven't gotten over it and
sometimes i flatten my neck out a little
bit and get my traps up a little bit
if i'm just walking and i see a guy
sizing me up
just so he knows you never know get
under hooks on you
double leg you single leg you break your
[ __ ] leg
we're gonna have easter send you the uh
colorado wrestling shirt
i appreciate that yeah i mean you could
wear that so it's a little tight oh you
know who i talked to today nate dawg
neymar cart you did he was with lex his
likes is he's doing deals for me and
he's like
hey you know i'm here with him like he's
like nate i haven't talked nate in
[ __ ]
10 years wow yeah how's he doing i think
he's getting back in fighting
he is yep all right all right well so
there's that
there's one of the greats yep nate the
great they called him ninth grade make
the great
i saw him last time i saw him was at aka
we went up there with luke and he was
sparring
and uh unbelievable there he is
look at him just a veteran a [ __ ]
veteran
who is that guy that is jake
a coach he's a boxing coach really good
coach damn he's lost weight too
huh man
man oh man a lot of jesus stuff uh yeah
sanford mma where's that at gin click on
it
amazing just say where it's at look it
up
yeah nate dog's back hey talks back
did you watch the fights out and uh i
did watch the fights i even put money on
the fights
i lost some money yeah what site did you
use to bet
bet u.s i think no no
sure yeah because they sponsored the uh
rough house friday
what was your bets i i took
i didn't bet on o'malley because i knew
that was a lock as far as i was
concerned
i bet i took hardy yeah i did too you
did
i just figured he's such an athlete and
no i i took him just because
on the fight campaign i just want to mix
it up yeah i i
uh bradley would only bet if it was like
a shoe-in as a calf the one that could
possibly
they're heavy weights greg's athletic
maybe you know
caution the win so i'll bet you that and
then yeah don't get a slugfest with a
samoan but that's what
that's what they do slash maori i lost
that one too yeah
yeah that that two of us is something
else and then um and i thought
wonder boy would be a very hard puzzle
to solve me too yeah
off night well or or gilbert burns is
that good and figures out a way to win
and his
his takedowns were awesome they seemed
simple but they were awesome and
perfectly fine i asked that one too you
did
but i but here's the the way i got
bradley to bet on is i said wonderboy
has to win by knockout
if he wins by decision then i lose so i
lost so i was down two grand at that
point
wow and then and then i got him to bet
on uh connor double or nothing
yeah so i was gonna be 4k in the hole
okay but i won that bet yeah i wasn't
brave i bet a hundred dollars on each
oh well that's a waste of time isn't it
a little bit of waste yeah also like why
bet
i know i know you got to get a little oh
i lost a hundred dollars gotta get the
juice going need juicy flowing
and i'm gonna do that with the tj
dillashaw fight corey sandhagen
that's kind of tj on food truck
yesterday yeah
no but i love him and and how's he doing
it's been a long time
i felt that suspension was way too long
three years two years okay epo
still too long epo i feel like eps is a
serious offense dude
well is it the same as as steroids
yes it is endurance
you don't get tired at 135 pretty big
advantage all right
but you know he's he's owned it and he's
moved on and he's moved on
moving on he's a great fighter and
nothing takes that away and i think
he's got his work cut out for him with
corey sandhagen great fight
san diego is my size and and you know
um but he's awesome brendan um was co
was tj on uh that stuff when he fought
cody
no oh and because i thought that they
were gonna have a rematch because i
thought
tj was on the server we don't know no we
do not know we do know
we knew you so the way you sata works is
when you test
hot for something like this they keep
they keep all your blood and piss tests
from all your fights so if they test for
that they go back and test
everything they'll pull all of them
they'll pull all of it wow
and they went back to test all this
stuff and he wasn't on it then okay so
there's so the narrative that he was
always on it isn't true
okay he was on it because he's cutting
down to 125 and he's looking for
advantage because the cup
he didn't think it would be that bad he
talked about in the show he didn't think
the cut was gonna be that bad
it was a [ __ ] nightmare sure so he
turned towards the dark arts
epo to kind of make up for it got busted
um did you obviously nobody saw conor
breaking his leg
but called it what if i was like you
called it what
huh well i think you know um one of the
things i heard a guy talking about was
the fact that
when like it was like same thing with
weidman when these guys
are training and they're kicking that
much they're they're using their legs
that much and
they're changing their training a little
bit and kicking and kicking and
conditioning their legs
sometimes if you haven't been doing it
as long as these muay thai guys is
you'll get hairline fractures without
knowing it
so you walk into the fight with your
your bone already a little compromised
when you've been kicking like that your
body hasn't had time to rush enough
calcium and make the bone harder
and that might be what he's been kicking
since he was eight years old he has but
i wonder if it's been
that kind of kicking right that isn't
that kicking it has yeah
he's always been a kicker but he uh i i
think it's the
the inactivity i think you know it's the
activity hasn't been
doing it you know he's been doing his
thing and then you know
[ __ ] happened sometimes and then also he
you know he did get the
one of his kicks got checked then he did
hit [ __ ] pour his elbow so
also you've been cutting that weight i
watched some of that muay thai stuff
they fight they're
really close they're kicking a lot of
times they're hitting each other with
the upper part of their shin
not that lower part as much so you know
it's just different it's a bummer
yeah that sucked still promoting his
fight still promoting
will they fight again who knows dude
because you're you're assuming that poor
a's can be in the same position
pouring is probably gonna be charles
oliveira so you think conor hasn't won
a fight in five years can just come back
from that one no
from no basically he's gonna have a year
and a half layoff
and you come back and fight the chant
it's a nightmare like you can't no
no that's a nightmare yeah we'll
probably fight an idea
yeah and then something like that it's
tough man of course it is the way he's
handling stuff too poirier oliveira is
great fight god damn there's no rest
no they're they're not gonna do it for a
while yeah
i just mean there's so many killers yeah
just waiting in the wings
tough way to make a living i'd rather
lift weights and get thick as [ __ ] what
are you weighing right now
what do you weigh oh i know i meant to
tell you daddy jay's chase three hundred
pounds no i'm 244.
he's are we buying he's shorter than you
but he might be a little thicker
look at his tits man yeah oh
when you get jay talking about
weightlifting like he'll just like we're
talking about strength
and some guy you know it's talking about
how strong he was and jay goes like that
he's just that
i said but i mean he's he probably looks
away he goes he he's sitting down we're
in the
you put five hundred dollars he goes if
you put 500 pounds on the ground right
now i'll get up right now and lift it
right now
dude how about max come back saturday
night yeah
i'm so excited welcome back daddy no
because it doesn't matter if you're
vaccinated
you can wear masks you know what i love
but here is what's weird so it's just in
la county you know the the state of
california is like
we're not doing that yeah just la county
yeah and then and then they're like oh
we want more people to get vaccine
well why would you get vaccinated if you
have to wear a mask still right
like you're shooting yourself in the
foot it's crazy so [ __ ] annoying
in france which is very anti-vaxx let's
say
you know
why i don't know they've just you know
francis has always been very progressive
and very kind of like
you know it's a lot of things but um the
uh the president marcon said when i was
there he said
that he is thinking about making it
mandatory you're getting a vaccine
and in europe but they can just do that
in europe but does france have a
well yeah i mean well france so in spain
when you go to san sebastian or
something
there are 90 of the people are wearing
masks on the streets still
in space yeah europeans because italy
got hit hard right yes but europeans
have never they they don't have a
problem following rules
so if the government says you have to do
this they'll a lot of times
they'll do it the italians are a little
bit different the italians like ah [ __ ]
off i'm not paying taxes the greeks
but overall there's a history of
following the rules
americans naturally and i think this is
a good thing
just go go you're [ __ ] telling me to
cover my face
and stand six feet apart already [ __ ]
you already i got a problem
all right now you know but people are
dying all right all right i got it
and then i gotta close my business down
double [ __ ] you yeah
how long and then so we're always on the
verge of [ __ ] grabbing our pitch
we also have a reason though right like
especially with with newsom and the
government and fouchy
his emails and like all this stuff like
good reason be like hold on hold on
we're all about saving lives here but
tell us why exactly right
i think that if you would just tell us
why you more people would be on board
i want a clear understanding don't just
when you just go just happen
dude americans go whoa dude come explain
it to me
because i think that that it's very
important as a population of americans
to always be pushing back and asking
questions agree i don't i
i what do you mean just do this that's
right who the [ __ ] are you that's what
makes america good yeah who are you
i don't like you but me and jerry talked
about last night when we saw um
that that could be in effect on saturday
at midnight
because that's when it you know that's
when it covers really striking saturday
at midnight
yeah so uh it's gonna be interesting to
see how what kind of pushback there is
because you you know newsome with this
recall oh do you think this is gonna
help
bubba yeah like or is it it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter because he he has the
power right to
to do his thing it's the health
bureaucrats though
right it's the health director of l.a
county
i think the lady who looks like a white
walker we're going to bring her up for a
second let's just
listen to the white walker on health
yeah now that kid right there should be
he dude he tells me dude if he goes dude
you know what you should take is more
glutamine i'm like [ __ ] yeah i know
look at his [ __ ] hair dying his
hair's so shiny are those veneers
are those veneers i'm gonna run my
fingers through his [ __ ] hair are you
vegan yeah
you're vegan i'm [ __ ] vegan no hold
on how old are you bro
29 yep yeah jesus all right 29 how long
you been vegan though
since i was 14. man before it was cool
man
right damn it i was hoping for like six
months i'm like just wait dude
yeah back is going to break all right
real skin is possible vegan so you don't
have any no no dairy nothing you're
glowing
what are you so like for lunch dave what
are you going to have a wrap or some
[ __ ]
just a salad yeah a burger no well easy
wings so what do you what do you
when you say burger you're eating like
those impossible [ __ ] things no like
a veggie burger
veggies yeah that's better for you than
you don't ever crave a steak or a
[ __ ] bacon
have you ever had a like a nice flaming
young or a [ __ ] prime rib
at all and you don't miss it at all yeah
yeah
your slime makes the difference his skin
looks good no he looks good dude you
juicing all the time and [ __ ] dude green
juice and stuff
smoothies you got a girl yeah mary
you're married yeah oh you're married
you shouldn't she's vegan too you'd have
to be right
i would imagine and what do you do for
protein um
a lot of questions here a lot of soy pea
protein avoid the soy
pea protein yeah
[Music]
whatever you're doing keep it update
don't listen to us i know especially
don't listen to
the [ __ ] yellow are from sin city
over here look i look in the mirror now
i'm like nope
i'm [ __ ] look at lee my face is
bloated he looks like [ __ ]
we're giving you advice look at him
compared to what i just did you know
what i was eating in france only
i was eating all the cheese and i was
eating wild boar prosciutto
was it fantastic yeah [ __ ] delicious
and then drinking all did you shoot your
pants though yeah yeah
yeah i did and i don't wipe anymore this
is the health secretary
health secretary well that's rachel
ravine um
of l.a you've never seen her hey are you
bullshitting us about being vegan
no dude why would you make that up but
they're all alive and in the corner
well you don't like to be on camera and
keep [ __ ] bringing them over no
that's not him dude
it's the lady that looks like a [ __ ]
white walker there's here she is
there she is she looks super healthy
death threads oh yeah i'ma listen to
those two on health
it's amazing i'm listening to those two
like michael jordan's bodyguard god and
she's telling us
how to be yeah it looks like michael
jordan the guy that made the bet with
him
remember him won i mean i don't like
making anybody for how they look
especially since i'm getting older but
jesus
jump i mean make an effort it's not even
that it's just i i
here's my thing if the rock came out it
was okay guys here's what we gotta do
like
it gets in pretty good shape yeah i'm
gonna listen well the rock's a little
bit of a tough example because he's
he's his whole name no he looks like a
summer squash dude
dude bring it br summer squash dude
bring him up now that he's getting ready
for to play that whatever the black adam
would it was
just he's just all veins oh no he's
cutting down the plates more dates did a
thing on him
okay dude dude i'll go to play some more
dates
well there's instagram or youtube uh
place more dates
fingers that's i don't do it justice no
it's on platesmore dates youtube
because he's because he's he's trying to
lean out for to play that black adam
yeah dude
dude he is jacked [ __ ]
city who's that guy
is that the guy there he is see uh see
all right there
chin see it the rock has achieved final
form look at him in the black and white
him and then diesel hate each other
apparently they do yeah
look how jacked he is dude now i'd like
a little advice from him
i yeah well he was thinking on the right
there though on
on things like uh you know
pharmaceuticals but
even you know you don't care about his
diet right
not really i i think that's a lot of
that's a lot of gear you're running and
i just don't know i don't like his face
his face looks old it looks like his all
the skin is gone he's getting that body
fat
well look at that look at the lines that
are going all the way this way
bro his face no yours i have a good face
where's the mirror bro
hey listen you know i love you dwayne
johnson
my face is his face compared to you his
face is better
it's a little too dry you know his face
is better than yours i don't
i don't know if that's true jay no he's
better-looking
yeah yeah yeah younger too a little more
vibrant
hey come on hey come on how long we
gonna run with this come on
now brian kellen's face on the rock's
body then you got the next
top model yeah but i just that's not the
kind of body i like
really i mean in other words i think
it's just too it's too much here for you
too
he's always been that way though well he
had a
he's got a great genetics he's you know
he's he's got that samoan
that's an american yeah but i i don't
know i just think that's too much
i think when you get to a certain age if
you're running i think you guys are the
same
he's a little young he's fifth not he's
50 isn't he 50.
49 49 40 i don't know is that old
yeah i just don't it looks good for 49.
i didn't know
oh there's like 46 or something i don't
know man
i liked it when he was younger you sound
like the fat girl hating on the hot
instagram models
i don't her lips are too ugh okay
janine okay yeah because every guy
doesn't want to [ __ ] her see i think the
way you look is good
because you're out of the rock you're
not all veined up i think that's
[ __ ] yeah those veins are stupid man
basket
but you'd rather be like just a normal
thick dude
i guess or i'd rather look like the i
don't think so
i don't think that i think your skin
gets too [ __ ] thin
yeah his bank counts like yep we're too
thin yeah
he's doing something right dude i don't
know man i'd rather look like a bobcat
wrestler
are you gonna see uh are you gonna go
see space jam the new space jam
is it out dude i think it came out this
weekend
me and jay were talking about this
though it's like you know tiger's five
feet he
bugs bunnies like get the [ __ ] back
funny get the [ __ ] out of my face it's
so heartbreaking
i'm telling jay i asked tiger about
[ __ ] marvin the martian he's like who
the [ __ ] is marvin the martian they out
throw it huh
well it's like he's never been into it
looney tunes isn't present like there's
no
they're not oh yeah they don't grow up
with it no we did back in the day
so it's like you keep pushing the looney
tunes on us but they're not that's so
interesting she doesn't have a point of
reference
no like he knows mickey mouse from
disneyland but there's no popping
mickey mouse [ __ ] movie they know
like pixar and all that [ __ ] but yeah
so i bri like i'm like you want to see
space jam he's like i guess
yeah i mean come on it's bugs bunny dude
it's new cartoon movies like i
i don't know any of these guys damn got
a 38 of rotten tomatoes
damn yeah it's tough you watch any do
you watch that
netflix thing on on the tyrants i think
no chrissy d was telling me about her
it's great
yeah man they break it down dude i think
i haven't clicked on netflix in a
hot second yeah idi amin they got um
stalin hitler uh saddam hussein do i
definitely watch it
it's pretty wild man jesus christ
yeah is it it's good it's well done i
think so dude i'm it's the tyrant's
handbook
yeah i love all that how to [ __ ] how
to get there oh yeah how to control
basically a basically a blueprint on how
to become an [ __ ] mm-hmm yeah i'll
watch
that well how about that [ __ ] uh
in haiti how about that [ __ ] the
president yeah i know
america some some of them were american
citizens american trained
it's interesting right yeah because they
said a few of them they went into just
they said we've heard conflict and
stories like they said they did go in
first to just
like kidnap them yeah and then you see
the the
the doctor in florida who was behind all
of it because you want to be the next
president
so he put the team together really by
the way though
that's a little crazy like like think
about that and put a team together and
kill the president
mercenaries yeah and i'm gonna become
the president
i mean that was his plan yeah that's an
ambitious isn't it weird
yeah that's that's a that's an ambitious
to-do list and also to be a present
i don't know that's a lot it's
interesting though
do you know what island haiti is part of
do you know
what i what land mass what country haiti
shares the same land mass with
a lot of people don't know this well
would it it wouldn't be
uh because it's not far from havana
no but it's an island and it shares a
land mass with another country yeah but
people think
like haiti's really far but it's not
that much further
did you say france okay now now
haiti's in the caribbean france was a
colonized haiti it's not part of yeah
and then and then another
are you saying who owns it jay france
yeah no it it
it was you're saying what part of
colonized but then there was like the
actual land the other part of the island
was colonized by
spain and who would that what is that
country
so interesting people don't know this
it's really interesting just [ __ ]
tell us dude
dominican republic so the dominic the dr
the dominican republic and haiti are on
the same island and one half was given
to the spanish
the other half was french interesting
yeah and the spanish
kind of stayed there and kind of helped
the population that they had oppressed
kind of transition whereas france just
left and left uh i think papadoc
they call him papadoc duvalier in power
who was a brutal
they're what they're have i mean cuba's
offside problems haiti's having problems
ethiopia is having huge problems yeah
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on right now
though we don't hear about that's right
america rock wear your mask yeah what
yeah and that all comes down to systems
of government when you give uh
for example military dictators that kind
of power
when you have a system that allows
people to come to power like that you
better be [ __ ] careful
and that's why you have to always have a
revolving door
presidency no president for life
remember how george washington said
they tried to make him president for
life and he said i didn't fight against
george the first to become george the
second
and he refused the kingship which but
but i think if the people vote keep
voting for you like the i
like how there's a election every four
years so like obama i think probably
would have won a third right
like like if a guy's crushing it i'm not
saying he's crushing but let's say
he's like that big of a favor and he's
really good at his gig
it's like can we do some sort of so jane
where they can stay
another four madison and hamilton said
the danger with that was that as a
president if he's there for eight years
it's too easy to consolidate
power by the eighth year you've got your
tentacles everywhere and it's just too
easy and too many people will benefit
off you staying in power and that's how
you create
factions that become powerful
factionalism was a huge part of the
founding fathers worry there's a fly
i know i want to kill it i want a cat i
want to catch it like bruce lee but i
i haven't had a chance i will and then
just i released it
yeah and it sits on my shoulder as my
pad oh that'd be cool yep it sits on my
shoulder and i pedal your pet
pet fly they only live 24 hours i don't
know
i've heard that they slow down google
that [ __ ] chin
i'm pretty sure they they only live
tonight i weep over my flight oh dude
josh filled in for you on monday he had
a great idea
we had a great idea they lived 28 days
so you can have a pet for 28 days
i thought it was 24 hours me too wow
i've been lied to my entire life
um instead of shark week you know shark
shark weekend
hip-hop i love that idea i saw it
freaked out
i was shouting at i saw it on instagram
how could you not do a hip a week
but i was i was thinking about it that
night in bed it's gonna be very dicey to
get a lot of coverage with hippos
like we can't get in the water with them
no you can't just gonna [ __ ] us up well
when i was in africa
the guy said if you got on a rowboat if
you got in a rowboat
with those hippos you would be dead one
hundred percent one hundred percent
they would kill you the coverage can be
they don't give a [ __ ] about your boat
they'll they'll attack you but there has
to be some device we can be in where
they're not gonna [ __ ] it all
up right well dum-dum to kayak down
the congo river you know those guys did
that by the way
a hippo will kill you and so will a big
enough croc
i mean hippo weak dude these guys are in
there
hold on they sedated him
you got to sedate that [ __ ] because he
will
kill you look at that oh [ __ ]
yeah they're not hearing a peep out of
your [ __ ] crocs by the way
oh is that hippo week how many times we
do [ __ ] shark week dude
i know hippo hippos do they they uh
they're very territorial and they're
nasty and they're see that's that's the
problem they're too
mean for us to get a film crew around
yeah they are to me
also if you're in a big enough boat they
just hang out and they're all mad at you
so i was there and these elephants were
bathing themselves and the hippo
was was furious apparently i don't know
but the guy said the
hippo's really mad and we know what
hippo's doing they're mad they stare at
you they just
they just sit submerged like the other
thing about the hippo is to get
some action shots you know they're not
like blood thirsty like a shark
no so we had to come up with something
there's one where that that we gotta
tase them up okay
we gotta tase them up yeah
you gotta get them going a little bit
look at that kid look at that dude
what i don't know what's going on i
think that's photoshopped
i don't think no i think they're really
bored and they're in some part of the
world maybe he's feeding it though he's
sitting on top that's a wild [ __ ]
hip-hop where are there
hippos there are [ __ ] crocodiles yeah
they look like they're having a good
time
that's gotta be photoshopped i know
it's like a sanctuary or something
probably and then there's a hippo that
lives with people we saw earlier too
yeah it's [ __ ] stupid
so you know how that ends would you
rather go horseback riding or ride
hippos i don't listen neither don't i
don't like riding any animal
is that a statue no dude why is it so
hard for you to believe that these
people are bored as [ __ ] so this is this
is photoshop
that's photoshopped yeah that's right
that parts
now that part is where i draw the line
now that is a real picture here's the
thing about being a hippo too
you get these fissures in your skin
right your skin cracks
and you're hanging out and here's what's
really fun about being an animal
there is a bird a type of bird with a
very sharp beak that just sits on your
back
needle your flesh it just pulls the
flesh so you go underwater daddy
sometimes though in the dry season you
got you're in a mud
you're in mud and everybody's taking a
[ __ ] in the same place so it's 20
it's 20 000 pounds of [ __ ] and you're in
a [ __ ] pool
while a bird is eating your back it's a
good time to be an animal that's mother
nature
i just wonder if bad people are reborn
shitty animals like that
[ __ ] emperor penguins
you ever see you ever seen where they
huddle up with the [ __ ] storms coming
oh
it's hard and they're like eyes freeze
over oh they're like this all of my
they're all shaky but they take turns
from the middle of the outside oh it's
great and you gotta fight you know
there's a selfish one like uh uh dog i
ain't going out there
and you have an egg you got an egg on
there protect egg and you gotta protect
the egg and then guess what
then another storm comes and your baby
dies anyway yeah
oh my god what is that about just as
injured
well you know what because every time
they go swimming mr leopard seal
can't wait leopard seal you got shirt
great white yeah
the leprechaun tried to take off its
head yeah well there you go well it kind
of succeeded didn't it
and and by the way sometimes they uh
jesus play with you he looks pretty
gangster that's a good one
it looks like carrie from the movie
carroll that's the penguin it's pretty
gangster
covered in pig blood cat you've been on
well you're gone cats on this uh
binge of uh horror shows yeah i watched
insidious recently and there's a
character that reminds me of jay
the the he's a comedy relief in the
movie
yeah he's the he's one of the two camera
guys yeah bring him up jim he does look
like jay
jay what are you doing just all the
bench what was the character we benched
yesterday
is he is he how's his strength she's
strong either 315 for five
yeah i don't wait but but not a straight
the baby grill over here no what'd you
do
i did 385 for 10 i think you did 385 10
times
yeah there's there's that's like jeff
got him in the face with a shovel yeah
it's jay if he decided to be a ghost
hunter
hilarious it's like yeah that's jay if
he let himself go
that's jay that's jeffy who's the hound
from game of thrones
yeah that's jp is casted
the hound had a baby their jeans and had
a baby
insidious is scary i saw it insidious is
scary because of the
sound effects whoever produ edited the
sound in
did a great job what's the scariest
movie you've seen um
i think since up there man sinister when
i first watched it was scary
i think nothing scared me more than the
japanese ring
when i was a kid oh yeah because i was
way too young though you know yeah
there's a korean movie i saw that scared
the [ __ ] out of me there's so many oh
did you watch gin chin didn't watch jin
i was very busy this weekend no you
weren't
hey you know uh you know chappelle's
sick and uh
he has the black plague but he uh he
watched gin
last night he texted like dude it's so
good i'm like i [ __ ] told you
i just reviewed movie on uh rotten
tomatoes
you don't say me and my girl were bored
so we googled him wow
wow that's weird that's called uh it's
called gin
it's on amazon it's so good is it yes
it's in a room right or just a house it
has to be the cheapest move of all time
it takes place in a one bedroom up yeah
but that's the channel in the valley
what the [ __ ] is that that's his mom
daddy all right that scares the [ __ ] out
of me oh she's scary
good god why is she doing that well you
gotta watch the movie
oh it is good [ __ ] man
yeah those korean movies are no joke
it's not this is not korean right
the kid's korean i mean the kids have i
think the story originally is korean
because it's a remake i think
well what does jin mean it's my name
oh but i don't know what dj i am that is
your name yeah jin
and he still watching it's not c-h-i-n i
changed it to c-h-i-n when i was in for
the americans naturalized yeah
i like that name i know i do too i wish
i could go back i met a dog named jip
that uh and i know i know it's a weird
story
but it's in england and the dog is it
was like this little muscular black dog
looked like a
combination it was a combination between
i guess a pit bull and another kind of
terrier it's a stretcher terrier well
they use them
they use them it wasn't but they like
that a little bit but they use them to
go down holes and kill foxes
who end up decimating your chickens this
[ __ ] went down in the hole and
killed a whole family of foxes came out
with just red fur all over his face
really you have any pictures or videos
no his name is chip chip
he was cute but he had black eyes he's
yeah he was i call him little evil
killing fox
how was the food in england fish and
chips the standard i didn't i just
nj fish and chips three times a day out
there that's all we have vinegar
yeah that's our thing we grew up with
that you know oh you did you guys are a
couple brits too yeah we are
you're half bread yeah we're [ __ ]
pissed england lost dude
i was did you watch it out there yeah i
did you watch it in italy i watched ufc
i watched then i got to watch wimbledon
finals and then i got to watch that
[ __ ] awesome
final god damn could there be a hardest
thing to do could there be a hard
penalty kicks how about being the goalie
no pressure
and and penalty kicks like [ __ ] up
like that oh my god
oh my god then there's that was comedian
who got cancelled because he said lauren
something the
british committee he goes black guys are
terrible at penalty kicks
everybody came down on him yeah i was
like what do you think
don't tweet that that's what he tweeted
yeah black guys are bad at penalty kicks
like
yeah geeks you know do you mind he was a
good comic out in england
yeah he's a big comic really big famous
but you had to know what are you
thinking like
did you want to take a break yeah that
made no sense i give some creative
events jim all right
i look good dude i'm looking at the
monitor right now you look great you
want to see yourself
rock man see i love because cats cat's
full of [ __ ]
cat likes the grey i do like that she
doesn't cat likes the gray no her
boyfriend is very young
if cat i feel like i aged stevie about
five years she's he's looking older he
looks excited
he can't when he's at fighting man i was
like oh is he crying his eyes are [ __ ]
up you know
oh jesus you won't go to the doctor
how's his eye better
um he looks like he's crying at all yeah
it does kind of look like he's been
rubbing his eyes he has allergies or
something
poor guy i don't know he won't go to the
doctor let's get together let's have
dinner yeah let's do it awesome
now now me or what's your name
nick nick's a good name me or
handsome nick i love you but nick
i'm a straight man and i mean nick all
day dude
come on you know this dude you go come
on nick all day
why are we calling nick all day look all
day your name is nick all day bro
dude [ __ ] that night vegan nick some
people call him vegan nick not me and
brendan we call him nick all day
we call him green nick yeah cause i'll
tell you something right now brother
if we're if we're on an island
you and i are just getting bored dude
that's not gay
it's not gay if you're stranded that's
good attitude he and i go spear a bore
and you gotta go we gotta you can eat
the coconut but after a while you gotta
eat some meat
are you talking about eating his ass i
don't know that's what it sounds like i
don't know oh we're talking about eating
the cheese
we have to go that i don't even know the
guy that's what it sounds like what do
you got jen
oops jean cuts on the andy de frame
boots today that's cool
oh there's a zipper here too boots up
man i got my zipper
i got my uh nice we have sort of
matching shoes yeah
they're so comfortable did you walk
around europe in those yeah
just the stupid questions people ask
there's nothing yeah i i don't care dude
this episode of fighter and the kid is
brought to you by on it supplements
what do you need man alpha brain new
mood
we got freaking krill oil joint oil we
got protein powders
we got frickin coffee we got it all man
we got it all at on it mct
oil whey protein dark roast elk bars
warrior bars
fat butter protein bites protein bars we
got everything you need
to get your thick ass in shape you need
fitness gear how about some
audit kettlebells how about you can
stream workouts from your freaking phone
no reason to be out of shape these days
you've got on-demand workouts
at home fitness programs on at 6 barbell
on at 6
body weight programs you can save 10 sun
off when you go to on it.com
fighter for everything i just told you
about man the best supplements on planet
earth
the best workout gear on planet earth
all come from on it in austin texas
on it.com fighter 10 off okay so you
guys were talking about jeff bezos going
off
into space recently and there was a 18
year old
some super rich 18 year old from
australia who was a part of an auction
to see if he could get a seat
on the first space trip out with jeff
bezos
and his brother he won it by bidding 28
million dollars
only to reschedule because he has a
scheduling conflict with something else
but he but he is going to go he is going
to go he's going to go on the second one
i don't think john
and his brother is going to be on the
second one no he's a smart guy he's like
i don't want to be the first one you
know i'm going to hold out and let's see
how it goes for you guys
well i want to know what they do so that
you break they go like this dear
you go up and then you come back down
right hold on right back down
you're not like up there like floating
around like damn space is dope you're
literally touching the top
you can do a motivational speech like
homeboy did and then go right back and
it's not that
safe there is a chance you can burn on
the way back in
yeah i'd like for all those [ __ ] to
have a little turbulence you know what
i'm saying a little turbo a little
something
keep them on the edge of their seats how
long does it take how long does that
trip take do we know it has to be a hot
second right how look up how long that
virgin flight was jen
no can't be that long
they went very high in a plane yeah they
went to the edge of
they went to the edge of the earth
that's what branson did that's what
richard branson
didn't but he didn't break the
atmosphere it's a very different thing
90 minutes that's
it and it takes me six hours to get to
new york
yeah [ __ ] you man yeah
yeah i uh i don't it's not my thing and
then he landed and he was all like yes
you did nothing dude yeah you paid for
this thanks dude
do you hear about the guy who jumped
from the edge of the atmosphere yeah
it was crazy yeah what kind the [ __ ]
march 2018 sir
yeah that's pretty cool yeah that was
cool that was badass
well i think the baddest guy is the guy
who [ __ ]
jumped and uh
landed in a net and didn't have a
parachute have you seen that guy
that guy who just who flew to where the
net
but he's in a squirrel suit he's in a
squirrel suit but you better he jumps
from the earth down to there and
calculate
properly because he jumped out one of
the highest places
and flew i think was 12 miles and then
landed
in a [ __ ] again what's the point
though well that that's crazy because
you don't have a shoot so you're gonna
die
right quick that's crazy
you know without using a parachute but
he
but he jumps off like see that thing he
fell into that i mean
[ __ ] that's crazy to me
25 000 feet so he's still not top of the
earth you know yeah
i mean it's cool without
deploying a parachute this does nothing
for me i have no interest in this
look at that
exactly that this thing that just
happened i mean the words i want to say
i can't even get out of my mouth it was
jesus christ and this kid and his wife
are watching right now you're out of
your [ __ ]
who's his stylist dang cook why is he
dressed like that
what's he doing can he get a can he get
a break no
he jumped 25 000 feet beat you could do
it i demanded you be able to
do it i could never do that i could do
that he jumped
without a shoot if he makes one mistake
he dies you could do that no i couldn't
he did he didn't have a skill he just
doesn't have that that
thing that tells him not to jump that's
a skill persona no because you gotta
they were born with that you got to fly
that's years of practice no that's this
no it's not you know you're not jumping
there you got to calculate the wind you
fly
to the target that's what he's doing
sure be impressed immediately
how are you not impressed with that
don't care he could die yep
well don't be all like eh he's the only
person that's ever done it
there'll be more well now yeah
goddammit that's good coffee
that's nice where daddy messed up though
is uh yesterday uh tj brought his own
food truck and it was a juice truck
so daddy drank a bunch of green juice
and then i drank their coffee mix
and then i mean then me and jay took
tiger to jiu jitsu well next to jitsu
is my favorite al's hot chicken
sandwiches and i get the hot sandwich
so when you mix all that yeah in the
middle and i woke up went well i'm gonna
[ __ ] my bed your shitter's going
oh dude i dude yeah
and then you just yeah not fun now it's
a disaster that's more impressive
getting through that not shooting your
pants than that guy jumping out of the
plane
your [ __ ] was burning a little bit
huh that was all right yeah
it's been a tough morning i still got it
look at me
oh cat you know how i told you that the
hottest sandwich yeah in the world me
and jay looked more into it and there's
there's a thing where if you order the
extra extra hot sandwich you have to
sign a waiver
on the waiver it says it's 2.2 million
on the what scales shoes
scoville do you know hot so so i don't
know so pepper spray
is like 1.8 million this is 2.2
what's christ this is what the bring it
bring up the [ __ ] what's he saying
the point of having something that spicy
who's eating it
i thought maybe you would what that's
why i'm telling you about it oh you talk
all that [ __ ] about
nothing no spice bothers you no spice
bothers me i just handle it well
well let's find out i think you're
hyping it up more than i am that's just
2.3 million on this
and this is 2.2 higher than pepper
spread and pepper spray
two of the world's hottest chilies one
of one of which is 250 times hotter than
that
did you get a hot jalapeno literally how
hot that chip
that we did i don't know in comparison i
was so hot that was gonna die from that
somehow okay well that's why you gotta
sign a waiver
at al's hot chicken i mean that'll burn
your [ __ ] stomach lining
the chicken's so tasty though but that
hot come on it's hotter than pepper
spray yeah your [ __ ] mind
come on because the ghost pepper is not
even it's not even close to that
nine million oh my god there's no way we
could do that damn sandwich
no no that's crazy nine million that's
what it says here
no we have a million
what says right here right you tell me
that chip is hotter than
i don't know i don't know if nine
million it was hot
it was hot as [ __ ] i don't know if it's
nine million scoville it's hot
no i mean it was [ __ ] intense but
nine million well since that was good
folks
yeah 1.5 so this chip is 2.2
oh yeah i can't eat that sandwich oh the
one chip challenge is dangerous and can
lead to death dude have you tried that
chip
no my girl tried it threw up everywhere
really yeah
and you know what's not fun is that
throat the throw ups just as hot come
back up yeah because
it has the acidity from the double two
so she ate she ate it and
threw up like 20 minutes later it was
just too much oh
so hot dude and what did her mouth
marathon must have been i mean you know
on fire dude
habanero peppers are hot enough eat one
of those and see what happens not that
hot
that's the haunted ghost pepper
did you try chin yes everybody in the
studio had it the only chappelle's one
that took a little
baby bite but we did the whole thing see
if it's killed anybody has a one chip
challenge killed in there
it's right there there's some idiot had
to die no i guess yet no one died
i figured someone would choke on the
chip or something [ __ ] that man
hey fly [ __ ] things make me mad man
i wish he'd eat that chip what else you
got jen i thought i'm gonna bring my
salt gun
okay so the goalie for the columbus blue
jackets
died on the fourth of july due to
fireworks
i guess a firework hit him in the chest
and because he had so much trauma to
that area he ended up passing away
during his memorial one of his teammates
went up and talked about the incident
saying that
if it wasn't for him getting hit uh
this hockey player his wife
who was pregnant at the time would have
died and then 50 people who were also at
the event with them would have been
injured
and so he saved a bunch of firecrackers
what is this mortar
he also fell in i heard he fell and hit
his head on the way out of the hot tub
to help them too
jesus christ so it was just like he
jumped in front of it to say
[ __ ] he wasn't he was young too
24 yeah
well that's a bummer wow
yeah what a shitty way to go firecracker
a firecracker so they just stuffed a
bunch in a mortar to shoot him in the
air i guess and then he got
caught with it but why was it pointed at
every now and then sometimes it falls
over and then starts shooting in a
different direction it's not good
yeah that's such a well that's where you
want to get the [ __ ] away from that area
yeah i don't know
i don't really [ __ ] with firecrackers
anymore so there is a
supposedly 14 year old basket player
somewhere in china
who is seven feet four inches let me see
it looks insane he's playing with other
14 year olds that's a woman but yeah oh
that's a girl technically that's a huge
[ __ ]
i mean come on dude get what it reminds
me of that i'm from rush hour three do
you remember
it reminds me of kramer when he's
playing with the taekwondo kids and he's
a black belt
but also it's like come on man play with
the grown women
yeah get this big girl in the wnba 14
though
that's so young yeah but there you can't
have a seven foot i know
well she's seven four seven four that's
she hasn't even hit her growth spurt yet
she looks slow
as [ __ ] yeah we got problems with your
bones and everything else
she's also 14. she's going through
puberty
she's 14. that's it let her lose her
that's poor thing that's good for her
brian well first of all she scored 42
points and 25 rebounds
six blocks here's the thing right
42 points i mean i just feel like it
should be 100 she should score 100 in
the game
do you think could beat her in
basketball
no checkers i'm no pretty quick
basketball dude really quick are you
thinking good beater
14 year old did you beat a 14 year old
you're
terrible at basketball could you beat
that 14 year old though probably
you think so just a really good athlete
not a chance how would you score you get
you don't have a jumper so you'd have to
drive
she's just gonna stand there at seven
yeah but i'm like get that back
and then i go like this yeah i'd beat
the [ __ ] over
i'm not i'm not a basketball player no
i i think she's i think she would beat
you i think she'd be i would i would
imagine
really probably probably you think
when when uh what's his name i do i
don't even play basketball that well but
i think i could beat her oh wow that's
sexist when what's his name did you beat
her christian lebron james was 14. i
haven't shot a basketball in i think
five years so i have no idea when lebron
james was 14 i guess he was the best
high school basketball club player in
the country
including 18 year olds he was 6'4 235
yeah so so i couldn't beat him at 14.
well he's lebron james we're talking
about this big but i was asking him i
asked my friend when
would i when could i beat let was this
like 10 years ago when could i beat him
when he's four
when he was my friend when you're 15 by
the time he was 12 he was going to be
oh i at 10 you would have your hands
full of lebron james at 10 yeah
but i think when he was four and you're
50 you could beat him yeah
that's it though that's your one shot no
i mean 10 10 years old
no no you're not being a ten-year-old
lebron james of course i am not sure you
don't play basketball
all that kid does no chance come on
take that back 11 10 11. i watched these
little bastards play
uh [ __ ] soccer the other day in this
competitive league they're all mexican
at five they beat the [ __ ] out of us
they're so if we did like a penalty kick
thing with them they'd beat the [ __ ] out
of us
it's intense what else you got jen
all right let's do this one real quick
it's an update on that girl
the corrections officer the hot one so
this is her
getting sentence i believe oh yeah what
are you doing they lay the law down on
her
wow how long is she doing i don't know
what she's doing but let's
sheriff steve see says
things in 26 years at the sheriff's
office but what his former correctional
officer tina gonzalez did
is at the top of the list no it's not
cutting a hole in your pants to make it
easier
to have sex with an inmate and having
intercourse and full view of 11 other
inmates is something only the parade of
mine can come up with
oh [ __ ] mccoma says gonzalez betrayed
her oath even worse when she put her
fellow correctional officers that's the
problem
she gave yeah that's why we gotta put
her away for a little bit
and at times communicated sensitive
information to the inmate about
individuals that were entering the
inmates pod
as well as times and place it or at
times when the got that gonzalez didn't
say anything in her sentencing tuesday
but her attorney said her marriage was
falling apart
when she started a relationship with the
inmates obviously listed more than a
year before investigators caught her
and phone calls a lot of different
december 2019 arrests
reveal it's continued the fact that she
continually
calls as sexually explicit conversations
yeah that's her man
and even most about the crime she
carried out shows that she's incapable
of loaning up her mistakes and will
undoubtedly continue in the future
this guy's a bit of a [ __ ] curiosity
he's a square gonzalez to jail for up to
16 months but noted
she had no prior criminal history and
admitted her crimes
early i think what you did was terrible
stupid
you ruined your career you endangered
your fellow officers
but i also believe that people can
redeem themselves you got the rest of
your life to prove that
gonzalez only has to serve 210 days in
jail and with time credit
that judge is like you know what you're
really [ __ ] up but you are smoking hot
and i forgive you
that's fair we want to go to jail
forever what the [ __ ] are we doing here
i mean the biggest thing with a guy the
biggest thing is
is smuggling in like the contraband well
that's a can't happen but was it razors
to shave or was it right
shank other inmates yeah that's that's
very strange
cut the hole in the pants look she's
she's into the guy she's still
kind of hot she's still dating him yeah
for a year yeah yes
i would love to see the inmate here's
what i got for you you got you
you son of a [ __ ] so i got a deal i got
plenty of dms from people that say
they've known her
from uh lamore right and then someone
they said that she was very and by the
way this is
it's not facts it's just like water cool
chat yeah so then someone sent me the
picture she
said this is a guy so i'll show you the
picture yeah she
guess what he is fall in love with
somebody in jail he's a black man who
runs the yard
black guy i'd say latino bettina yeah
i'm gonna say white
i would say you guys are all right cause
he looks sort of like a mix
handsome guy that's latino
i don't know what the [ __ ] that is that
he's a handsome guy he's probably he
looks like he's probably latin of some
latino of some kind
he's a hazard yeah listen whatever it is
listen you're not gonna hole in your
pants if the guy's ugly you know what
i'm saying like i knew he's gonna be a
dime piece yeah
he has the tat on his neck mm-hmm yeah
so so she
isn't a sh he's like he's latino by the
way that's not a
little bit of a black problem she meets
a guy
she probably hates her life i didn't
like her husband and then she falls in
love with some dude or
lust or whatever they have a thing and
now she's yeah public enemy number one
the razor thing is a problem the other
thing is
you know i mean they need entertainment
but letting the other 11 11 people watch
[ __ ] that's very interesting what's that
about maybe she's into that it's hot
she might be in a yeah or that was the
only place he could do it yeah i mean
i don't know i don't know what to say i
mean yeah i bet he's like dude you try
telling these [ __ ]
savages to look away like what dude they
haven't seen a girl in years it's kind
of easy to see through
your [ __ ] telephone i tried they're
all watching jacking off
right and plus it looked like they were
enclosed maybe that's why she cut the
hole in her pants so
they're still [ __ ] without her
actually showing anything yeah or even
through
the bars or something right no oh no
it's through the bars yeah for sure why
is three yeah
that's what i'm guessing i mean we can't
pretty sexy yeah they really transfer
inmates yeah she's gonna be fine when
she gets out
now how long do we know how long this
kid's in for no we don't know anything
this is literally someone just messaging
me this
we also don't know says keep me
anonymous please i know someone who
works for fresno county
hell yeah wow case solved
this was a cold case this was a cold
case for three weeks like going around
your head right now
yeah he's our friend yeah i'm gonna kill
him and i'm gonna kill him i want to
he's not gonna land though dude
when he lands he's dead he's a [ __ ]
dead man
he only has 27 more days to live though
what else you got
wow good work good investigative work
yeah i have a fly gun i have a number of
them
i'll bring one in yeah bring one in and
i'm gonna kill it i mean we're leaving
today but yeah come back on your own and
do it
hey i get that fly into the old studio
damn it
drive back hey you there man i can't
find this [ __ ]
do you leave the door open because i've
been here for an hour
you didn't see the note to leave the
door closed two hours later hey man i'm
getting really pissed are you there
you're not picking up
this [ __ ] fly there he is uh
exotic also known as joseph maldonado
passage just two years
into a twenty two reset so he's going to
get out early
so his sentence is already vacated so
he's going to be re-sentenced because of
another flaw some sort of
instance hopefully he gets out and they
do another [ __ ]
dock on him yeah his problems right it's
kind of similar to the guy who did the
silk road [ __ ]
like he hired somebody to kill another
human being
we can't have it but she's a tiger king
star carol baskin claims joe exotic
rivalry was fabricated
for a netflix show yeah but that's fine
but the reason he's in there is because
he killed these tigers he shot him in
the head and then he also
hired a gunman to kill her
deal with her by cutting her hat off i
can't have that
oh yeah you can't if you're gonna hire
somebody to kill somebody
you're guilty of yeah murder attempted
murder yeah that's what you're doing
yeah so he could potentially get a lower
sentencing because of the recents it's
cool he's still gonna do a couple hard
years
um this is just a quick one
tristan thompson was commenting on
chloe's
post and then well she posted a pretty
suggestive post right she looked like a
dime piece
and then lamar odom who's her ex goes
hottie
and then tristan does like here's what's
fascinating both of them cheated on her
and then lamar gets on the and then uh
real tristan says lamar and god brought
you back the first time play if you want
different results and then he replied
with this i mean you're not kidding he's
gonna actually die this time
why would why would tweeting at his
ex-girl
cause him to tweet that though what is
that it is weird because he cheated on
her
and then they they broke up and then her
ex posted on there
and then he smelled that he posted the
comment on there
trying to get back together though oh
really oh so is this tristan thomas
right here
this is a different retweet retweeted
this video remember this one
fergie
she's all bad look at them all loud
[Music]
why'd she [ __ ] up like that she said was
trying something new at a cigarette that
was so bad
god damn it's fergie what could you
that's hilarious she was trying
i don't know if this is legit but brian
redman posted this
bill cosby on instagram it looks healthy
i just got a fresh cup from my birthday
dinner tonight in words of james brown
it's a man's world but it wouldn't be
nothing without a woman
wow i don't know if that's legit him
because he's not verified either but i
don't know why i would
verify them interesting yeah i just
thought it was interesting
um what happened oh
[Music]
so do you guys know much about richard
sherman yeah
okay so you know the incident they
talked about for
no he's not he's he finally retired no
he's not retired but he
he's a free agent right now right he's
30 something years old i'm sure there's
a little bit of ct
there he got drunk and this is the girl
his girl's fault that's pretty crazy
he thought he was going to be able to
kill me
[Applause]
and they're all freaking out and
screaming
[Music]
i mean who would let that guy in their
house
why isn't he doing well i'm scared
trying to fight
it's just more that but that's the
actual footage that they
caught man uh it looks like a fight with
his girl
no his wife's no his wife was like yeah
i want to be very clear he didn't hurt
anybody
like that he needs to get help because
he's starting to kill himself too oh
that's where he gets dicey yeah he kept
threatening to hang himself
okay all right yeah that's not good
passionate guy but
i don't know what that was so since that
marie taylor controversy with uh rachel
nichols
espn wanted to give her three million
dollars to stay but now she's working to
deal with uh
the nbc sports that are gonna give her
more so she's most likely gonna leave
uh but who
doesn't is nbc owns uh
disney owns all of it right oh
so would you she would just work the
olympics and [ __ ] for them
i don't know but i mean because of the
controversy she's going to make a bigger
paycheck now
i mean she was getting paid either way
well not that much though not what she
wanted she won 9
has nfl million oh
nhl is probably not for her huh i don't
think she's into hockey
i mean nfl would be good though yeah
she's going to get paid yeah
so is rachel nichols all gone she's just
there she yeah they just took her off of
some of the broadcasts but i don't know
if she's gone she's not gonna be gone
right
i don't think so yeah yeah now there's
an opening
all right did you hear once you know
ariel helwani went on uh what's that one
show
dan lebotard is it daniel avatar john
lebatard
yeah he went on his show and talked
about dana white
yeah i talked about dana white how he'd
like constantly [ __ ] him over
he was like you know i started with espn
that's my dream i was there for three
years you know
you would the hopes was to resign he's
like they did make me an offer but super
low
he's like but i he like came out and
said how tough dana white made it for
him
he's like you know dana made it so like
if like he couldn't be in the back
or anything like that but if they did
like he couldn't be on the pre
show either but if he was there dana had
it so
he didn't want to like to even see ariel
so the the espn security like dude we
hate we have to do this but dana's
coming up here so we have to get you out
of his eyesight
so he was like dude so think how
embarrassing that is but i'm doing my
job
like hey dana's coming up here and he
knows you're here so we gotta take you
out the back
he's like for three years to three years
yeah
well ariel is he gets
he's he's i can see him annoying dana i
can see he's a good journalist i think
he asks tough questions yeah one of the
best
yeah if not that i mean as far as
journalist goes he's not afraid to
create
controversial questions and dana
probably got no that's not why i mean
it is it's just that you don't know the
story of tayden
i know i know i never liked him but i i
don't know well he he
kicked a lot of it kicked off with the
brock lesnar stuff he announced the
brock fight before the ufc did and
that's like a big no no since then he
you know he banned him from the ufc dana
asked him not to do it too because they
were kind of cool before
he's just don't do this one and he did
it anyways he did it yeah that's where
it all went downhill
all right so uh mac and cheese ice cream
sold out in one hour
wow sounds disgusting wow
people love it it's from kraft too it
might be good it's from kraft
kraft has shitty mac and cheese though
yeah it's fantastic you ever had the
cheese the the shells and cheese
yes i have what mac and cheese do you
eat
what what mac and cheese do you eat i
don't eat mac and cheese
oh annie's is good actually i'm better
than craft though annie's is great but
crap
is a goddamn american staple
what you don't like crabs it's tiger's
favorite food in the world yeah i'd eat
it right now it's tiger's favorite food
i'm also raised by refugees so there's
that taste bud's a little different
well me and jay grew up on the macro and
cheese dinner
which is also a black and white box to
be fair
just the bun they're from rhode island
they were 69 sir that's what our dad
made and look at the
look at the size of you kids you guys
grew up mac and cheese dinner
the spirals come on daddy cup of thick
balls oh it's nice one right to your
tits and shoulders congratulations and
dicks
and well jay of a dick on him he dwarfs
photos
it's impossible it's an impossible and
it's
black i'm just being honest it's very
dark
it's mermaid yeah it's made to be in the
sun
you're making him so nervous i know he's
just quiet and he's all like jay and
nick at night hate being on camera but
he and i
yeah he and i are a couple i wonder if
they can knight has a big one
all day no it's nick at night what did i
say it was originally
i called nick at night now we're calling
him nick all day no nick at night
nick all day no no cause nick all day we
choose nick all day
over no nick at night well nick at night
when we're on the island
you understand what i mean and then also
nick all day yeah
hey what's for dessert nick all night
don't have any chocolate
whoops whoops i thought i was straight
this whole time still am but you know
that kind of stuff sure now back to you
and your [ __ ]
dong that goes on his dark dick it's got
an elbow it's got an echo itself the
dark wing does got ears and long the
dark knight makes noise
yep and you're all i know but
he's all like he and i are a couple
peakers we try to get a peek at it
and he's like i've seen i've seen jay's
dick six times
that's it crazy and your brothers he
always hides it it's amazing
yeah get it out man don't be so shy yeah
don't be weird about it yeah don't
turtle
god gave you that cool gift man
it's dark for a reason because it needs
to be out yeah
you're weird yeah but back to you and
hating craft what the [ __ ] man
i didn't really when's the last time you
had it probably
in actually have you ever had it uh high
school
i feel like i've made it for my baby
brother at one point
it's so good it's fantastic it's all
right i never i'll make tigers and i'll
take a big spoonful and eat it before he
does
me too the only way i finish it is if i
put a bunch of sriracha on it
okay no that's not what we do
again raised by refugees i might make
some tonight no you're not
it's the best i ate too much cheese and
you know it's it's also it's also
nice the few days after too yeah it
stays
[ __ ] fresh man and the shell
that was jade that's why you knew we're
doing well in life when jay was eating
shells and cheese
is that cheese it's like the nacho
cheese you put in there and you mix it
up with the shells
come on daddy mac and cheese that bill
gates mac and cheese
dawn yeah little mac and cheese
oh the velveeta one's super fancy really
are you rich rich eating velveeta
yeah that that [ __ ] no is that better
yeah because it comes in like a a
foil cheese see it says liquid gold
it's like real cheese annie's mac and
cheese ain't bad bring that up for a sec
and he's that's you get that at whole
foods right yeah that's the organic
the [ __ ] out of my face man the pasta
was better than annie's i think
what is everyone's like an expert now i
mean
nah dude compared to [ __ ] the
original craft
crafts like the four to [ __ ] macaroni
and cheese man there's nothing more
american
it is hey get that [ __ ] out of here chin
it's hard aged cheddar
no i i like the artificial flavoring i
like all that [ __ ] in there
yeah well they they it's hard
it's a staple what is it though
it's like a powdery mixture it's a
disgusting powder
it's just dehydrated cheese i mean
caught cheese is even unfair i don't
know what it is yeah
it's fantastic i ate a pigeon head what
in france
they said do you want the pigeon i go of
course i do and they picture that there
and it was just really fast rats of the
sky and uh yep and it was this
it was a pigeon so i i ate uh
they give you the i didn't know what it
was and they cover they
hold up a [ __ ] napkin in front of you
yeah and so you and they just grab that
and when i grabbed it and ate it i
realized i was holding onto the beak
and i ate the [ __ ] head of a pigeon
did you play a joke on you no it was a
deep-fried delicacy
was it deep fried i don't know they made
it in this crazy sauce and you just go
and you don't you eat his face and i ate
the whole [ __ ] head of a pigeon
what do you guys have pigeon bottles you
guys tied on cash pigeon
i don't know man it was weird with your
rich friend yeah and i grabbed that beak
and i went
this was a pigeon pig it was a wood
pigeon so it's like out there in the
yeah it's not like the pigeon you think
of but it's a pigeon that's pigeons are
pissed yeah it's a pitch with a little
bit bigger wingspan
but i ate the head we all did disgusting
and i was like well i'm not gonna say no
to that was it was it good
no it wasn't and i'll tell you the best
yeah i'm not doing that anymore foie
gras means
means fat liver well actually liver fat
is that that's like uh
what they call it well they take a goose
which i didn't know yeah they fatten
them up it's super
they stick it in humane
their liver gets 15 times the size and
it's like just because that's fun for
that
dude it's so delicious i'll never do it
again once i saw that okay
[ __ ] that yeah it's pate but it's super
fast you can't do that to an animal
like you're torturing the animals
they're feeding them butternut and
they're stuck there like that [ __ ] that
i'm never doing that yeah but you did it
you know well i did it
and then i then i was like how happy
that guy is to be
[ __ ] force-feeding that [ __ ] giant
goose yeah didn't they say that they
kind of like
go towards it though like the well i
don't know
that's what they tell you when they when
they have in china that china is the
biggest fog lawmaker and i promise you
in china they don't give up that's what
they're doing yeah they look thrilled
that's terrible definitely terrible they
burned their eyes off as well
it's super [ __ ] up oh [ __ ] dude
there's talents food
well now they have do you eat do you eat
snail out there too i did not eat
caviar i ate some caviar i don't like
caviar either
well if it's good caviar i'll eat it
i'll eat all the caviar i don't like it
and it's fish eggs sturgeon fish eggs i
know it's kind of disgusting but
just some sardines out there i had
sardine paste on a very special
disgusting do you eat some croissants
yes nice croissants buttered
yeah well they when you get the
croissants that come from the bakery
that they make
there see when you go to france you you
get everything in one specialty shop so
you buy a cheese here you put your
croissant here
man it's so good was it fantastic better
croissant than starbucks
hey man huh bubba hey big guy huh
it was just i'll come at you it was good
i'll come at you hey dude oh god did you
also drink it with
fresh milk no i don't drink fresh milk
but i think that's
stupid [ __ ] people say in europe you
know coffee fresh cold milk
yeah i had coffee and very special cream
we make better coffee than them not
anymore
same it depends yeah about the same this
chinese coffee you get great stuff
everyone has great croissants yeah we
had one yesterday yeah
jay deep throwed a sausage from iran
yesterday i did
so nice well i mean the sausage that you
bought
it's a maple sausage they have the hot
bar delicious where'd you see the new
studio erwin
you could throw a rock here next to it
yeah oh man it'll be okay
now you're not gonna you're not gonna
leave there without spending sixty
dollars every single time it's sixty
dollars can't you can't get out of there
without spending that much
you can't dude i bought a shake the
other day 22 that's right in what
[ __ ] world
and two croissants are nine dollars yeah
and i was like wow worth every penny
though
so good you you're yeah you're not
leaving there you're not leaving there
i've never left there and spent less
than a hundred dollars never it's
impossible whole foods on steroids
they ser they have camel milk
camel milk that's 32 dollars i'm not
going to buy it but well
that makes sense frozen who's nuts in
the can some camel milk
am i a bedouin what else you got that
one
i think that's pretty much it all right
dude we covered a lot
of stuff nick thanks for for guesting on
the podcast
nick at night and jay thanks for being
jay thanks for coming and bringing your
big black dick
yep you doing did you bench are you
squad as well
yeah you got any uh fitness tips if we
want to get thicker
a guy like me wants to get thicker what
do we do we ordered benny hanna's the
other night
jay ate it in three seconds really
so are you are you up in your calories
no i'm just hungry
but did you did you decide to get
thicker or you just started lifting
heavy because your body
has always been thick i've been i've
been looking heavier lately honestly
talking to mark
yeah because mark has got you on this
[ __ ] yeah on lifting i'm not saying [ __ ]
yeah
you're not doing [ __ ] yes he's doing
anna ball and all that [ __ ] probably
and a ball i don't know you got that old
man shut up man why don't you go kill
[ __ ] why don't you go do [ __ ]
steroids all day why don't you go why
don't you go
why don't you go shove a tube down a
geese's [ __ ] water
[ __ ] i'll stuff you [ __ ] i got
some stuff to stuff your gullet with
what uh why don't you go eat some
edanami with [ __ ] nick at night over
come to my stuff
station in my house i'll stuff you up
stop station yeah you're disgusting
nick all [ __ ] day and all night uh
what is today friday i got shows tonight
uh
saturday early show sold out saturdays
me and
chris distefano tonight is me and eric
griffin yeah good shows good shows
um yeah man few tickets left
yep tonight friday july 16th saturday
july 17th
all shows are more sold out some shows
are sold out j shop will be there
selling the thick boy merch can only get
in person
tacoma washington tacoma comedy club
july 29th to 31st
north carolina is august 19th to 21st la
jolla
comedy store california august 27th 29th
just waiting for them to send me a
goddamn ticket link
san jose improv september 9th the 11th
san antonio is september 24th
25th get your tickets at thickboy.com
vegas got rescheduled that's officially
october 7th through october 9th all
right that's it man
brian you're finally back you piece of
[ __ ] i'm back uh ontario
uh tonight if you if you're there i'm a
jam in the van that should be fun
um and then ontario improv july 29
30 31 houston texas improv
august 1921 i got a lot more dates but
uh
they're not the link isn't up yet so
houston improv
august 1921. ontario california the end
of this ontario's [ __ ] great too
one of my favorites i love it 29th 30th
31st i'm excited well we missed you
buddy glad you're back
love being here and i'm sure the pigeons
are happy you're not there anymore oh
yeah no more pigeon heading
all right we love you guys we're out
last time in the studio
last time